[Music]
let's go to sarah in indianapolis what's
up sarah
hi dr john this is so wild to talk to
you it's more wild to talk to you i
promise how are you oh
i'm doing good doing good
yeah how about you
it's exact same doing pretty good
so what's up how can i help
well i feel like a silly goose after
that last caller that was heavy man hey
man there it yeah there is no comparison
i mean there's no like comparing
heaviness man it's everybody's heavy is
heavy to them so that's awesome so
what's up
hey i guarantee you what you're about to
drop is big so go go no it's really it's
silly um okay
so
all right um
my husband has
friends from college that are having a
bachelor party at the end of this year
and i'm a thousand percent sure there's
going to be um strippers involved
uh
that's a that's a that's a a strong
degree of certainty there
i'm not well yeah i know that it's
awesome that's that's their guy you know
that's just like what they're into uh
my husband has made it clear to me in
the past that's like not his jam but
like you know those friends and whatever
um and this the reason why it's like a
bigger deal this time
is because like right before we got
married like he's made our whole
relationship he's like yeah i went in
college but you know like
if i don't like it like i just you know
i'd like to do with my buddies and stuff
um and then you know about a week before
we got married he had somebody else's
boobs in his face
and yeah so he did this for his bachelor
party
well okay his buddies you know
took him but yeah
so
anyway
poor guy just got forced right into it
huh right oh it's so fat no
man i i'm really sorry that
well
the thing is like i like to think of
myself as like a cool chick you know
like i like dirty naughty fun like i'm
all about it like a good time it was
just like a weird betrayal because like
he told me like he wasn't gonna that was
good so hold on hold on whatever it's
not a weird betrayal it's a
regular old spit in your face betrayal
that's what it felt like
that's what it was
it was honestly
yeah
and if it hadn't been you know the week
before our wedding and everything was
done i probably wouldn't have married
him but i'm glad i did i love him we've
been good since then you know we sought
it out
we uh you know we have a son like
everything's good now
um but now it's like i'm like
oh god what do i do because that's not
good now
it's not i don't know
oh no don't tell me that well i mean
you're
nothing has changed
you have a you have a boundary
and you have said
this violates what my understanding of
covenant is
okay
and this is important to me
and he has said i don't know where i'm
at with it though it's like the thing
like i don't because there i have like
three sides that i like ping pong around
all right let's play ping pong
it's like okay we're solid i'm cool like
this is fun like go out and have fun i
know it doesn't mean anything like if
she doesn't care that's her job like she
doesn't care about you and then i'm like
well
you know
screw him if he wants to do that then i
don't want to be with him anyway and
then i go
to the other side where it's just like
i don't know i don't know that's
cheating
even though you pay for it that's
cheating like some eyes like ping pong
between these three different
feelings
and it's like i just don't
i shared that
i'm going to resent him and then i'm
scared if he doesn't go he's going to
resent me
because i don't want to give him roles
ew like i'm not his mom you know what i
mean
oh sweet sarah
oh man
you're like the best in every category
you're just the best
okay wow
so
um
uh there's so much here geez louise
um
you do have thoughts and feelings on
this
and i don't wanna
i know you don't want them
and
here's what i think
i think the thought
of some other woman shoving her breast
in your husband's face makes you sick
yeah cause that's our thing man i do
that okay there you go that's your job
and it makes you sick and then layered
on top of that is well i want to be cool
and i want him to keep loving me
and on top of that is
but it makes me sick and so on top of
that it's like well i mean it doesn't
mean anything whatever
so let's take
this in my and this is totally me okay
this is less about
a strip
club this is more about i have values
and i have boundaries
and your values are important and your
boundaries matter
and the first time your husband spit on
him
and then just walked right through
and so he he banged up against your
boundaries and they didn't hold
and
you
not him you are the one who've had to
deal with picking those bricks back up
and putting the wall back up the
boundaries back up
and now it's coming again
and so this is less about is this
cheating or is this not am i the cool
wife whatever i've got friends whose
wives don't care
and i've got friends whose wives like
couldn't breathe when they caught their
husband with a bra ad out of a sunday
paper right so everybody's got different
values
yeah it is
asinine completely asinine
to say that going to a strip club is not
extramarital
sexual encounter full stop
now where like me and my wife disagree
on the conversation is i think cheating
is about secrets
and like i think you can cheat by going
to get coffee with somebody
like so i think cheating is about
secrets she is her definition of
cheating is different than mine hers is
about sexual encounters here's where
that that here's why i want to stay away
from that it doesn't matter i don't want
you to get into a semantics conversation
with your husband about is this cheating
or is it not cheating am i cool or not
cool
that's not that's not the issue here the
issue is your boundaries matter
well see i don't think it's about boobs
no no it's not it's about i want this
and he's saying no i don't i don't think
i care i really don't like because like
i said i like to have dirty naughty
phone like you do care sarah you care
well i think i care because it's like
you pretend to like be
somebody who doesn't like that and like
if you like that then just be honest
with me and be like yeah we're going to
a strip club it's going to be a good
time but you know i'm coming home you
know what i'm look does that make sense
yes your husband's not telling you the
truth
that's what it feels like it's like just
it's not what it feels like that's what
it is
and why does he do that
because you're not being honest with
yourself
you're not super cool with this
you don't think so no
but i want to be
great
you know what i want 20 million dollars
i want it so bad
you're on the right track man you look
sold out yeah dude
yeah it sold a bunch so i'm i think i'm
approximately
19 million 980 000 away from my goal
so here's the deal like
you you just
what do i do with this man
you have to own the fact that you feel
devalued
so then if i give him a rule
do i tell him not to go because that
feels yucky
what feels more yucky
your husband lying to you or your
husband
saying i don't really care how you feel
these are my bros dude
i i think he would
like listen to me if i told him that but
like i don't
so why why are you so afraid to tell
them what you think what you what you
find value in
why because i just like i don't know i
just like have this image of myself and
i want
to not be
i don't want to not care you know what i
mean like i want you
and it's okay trying to force yourself
to not okay here's a sideways example
and if this example goes off the rails
because it just came to me then they're
gonna edit it out and this will never
exist
okay um in when i was the dean of
students at a law school one of the
things we would do is i gave everybody a
question here i think it goes out of
southern illinois is a questionnaire
just on behavior practices how much sex
are you having how much do you drink how
much weed do you smoke when's the last
time you did cocaine right questions
like that
and
the purpose of this
was just social norming
just so you could find out really about
your classmates and then what i would do
is i'd get up and read the data and
here's what was wild they would ask
people the their questions about
themselves and then they would ask the
questions about what they thought their
classmates were doing
and there was always a significant gap
between how much
people actually drank
how drunk they were all the time
and how much people thought they were
drinking
because people thought they were people
were drunk 95 of the time and they were
really drinking 60 of the time
and one of the most damning statistics
ever and i'd get up and i'd read it to
the class because i was like hey here's
what you all think but here's what truth
is if you don't want to drink and you
think well 90 of the people are then
you're going to find yourself in a
situation that you don't like you're
going to compromise your own values
because you want to belong and the
desire to belong is so strong so strong
the one that used to break my heart
was the number of and this was
particularly among the female cohort of
students
the number of people who had to consume
two to three alcoholic drinks
to feel sexy to engage in sexual
behavior
and every year i got up in front of the
class
the whole crew and said
if you have to consume substances
to tampen down your own value system
don't
it's there for a reason
and you have a set of values
that mean something to you one of them
is honesty one of them is fidelity one
of them is you want to be the only
person
being all up on your husband
one of them is do you value me more than
your stupid college friends
right you've got these values wow and
you're doing
everything you can to squash them in the
name of cool chick
yeah
and hear me say your
values matter
so what do i tell him
what do i do john
what you feel
and what you know to be true
this isn't an argument about cheating if
if it's cheating for you then that's the
words you use and i'll honor that i
think it is it's just like it's it's
deceptive it's lying and it's i don't
feel comfortable with this
period
and here's my here's my promise to you
this isn't the only thing
right
sucks for you i've been doing this a
long time
[Laughter]
there's a bunch of stuff in your home
that you're not super down with
that you do everything you can whether
it's to smoke a little to drink a little
bit more to wear something a little
whatever it is
your your find ways to squash how you
really feel about a thing
to try to
live up to some fantasy some myth
mythical character you've created that
you think your husband wants
it's not even that i think he wants that
i don't know
it's just like me i guess
yeah
so here's how i've always been
everywhere i'm always the life of the
party like i'm always the loudest i'm
always like you know the whatever like i
always want to have sex with time you
know that's me that's like my yeah damn
well there's different between one have
sex all the time and being the life of
the party
one of those is
awesome one of those is exhausting
fair
which one's weird
i mean wanting to have sex all the time
with your husband's pretty awesome
um yeah wanting to always
it's a defense mechanism
being the life of the party it's a way
that you can wave your wand over here
and go everybody look over here so that
you don't really see what's going on
and i'm talking as a former life of the
party
now i'm a total drag on the party you
know why because i don't care
damn how do you get there
that was a lot of therapy for them it's
a lot
yeah there's a lot of therapy honestly
here's where it is it started with me
looking in the mirror and being honest
about what i felt about stuff
i had to start telling the truth to
myself
and i had to start telling the truth to
my wife and i started telling the truth
to my close friends
and what do i do
here here's here's the honest-to-god
truth
um i want to be very careful how i say
this
um
i don't want to bring people into this
unnecessarily
i've been in a lot of weddings in my
life
and i've skipped a number of bachelor
parties
and those people are still the closest
friends i have on the planet
and i'll still trust them with my kids
if i'm in the hospital
i would trust them with my wife
if i got deployed overseas
i love them and i trust them
and also i didn't participate in their
bachelor party
right and it's not a matter of judgment
it's a matter of me
i chose not to
right and so it's not an either or
i also go to bed at midnight when i'm
everyone's hanging out
i'm lame
my company's we're going to do an event
in vegas and i'm like dude how can i get
out of this i can go to bed at 11 not
get out of the event but
like when event's over at 10 i bet i can
be in bed by 10 45 i'm just not cool i'm
just not and my friends that are really
my friends they still love me anyway and
they make fun of me and they would but
it doesn't compromise my marriage and it
doesn't compromise my personal values
and it doesn't make me not love them any
less and it doesn't make them love me
any less right
so you've cr you've painted yourself
into a corner where if i do this then
he's gonna you don't know that
the only way forward is you'd be gonna
start telling the truth with yourself
and start telling the truth with your
values with him
and that's hard because my guess is you
have not done that a long time and that
doesn't compromise you
being a fun rambunctious sexy wife it
doesn't compromise that at all in fact
it provides infinitely more freedom
there
right now you're trying to be reckless
and fun
and you're shackled to a story
you wanna have reckless and fun
adventures in your bedroom
go completely unshackled
this thing's this my knowledge is really
getting ugly here it's getting pretty
pretty sideways pretty fast that's not
what i meant you know what i meant sarah
but listen
the fewer the fewer values you have to
tamp down the more energy you have to
expend
have excitement enjoy fun
i hate that you're in this situation
but how do you have the conversation you
sit down and have the conversation say
this is how i feel
and you're worth that you're worth your
values
you